Have you ever found yourself in
one of those moments, maybe, you
know, a routine traffic stop or
dealing with some bureaucracy,
and you just get that feeling,
that sort of sudden, almost gut
feeling of unease, like there's
something else going on,
something hidden underneath the
surface?
Yeah, like a gear turning
somewhere you can't see.
Exactly a bigger process kicking
off and you can't quite name it
but you know you're suddenly
part of it.
Well, welcome to the Deep Dive.
Today we're going to try and
pull back the curtain on exactly
that feeling.
We're dissecting a really
fascinating and maybe a little
unsettling perspective on power
and control and, well, human
behavior.
Our mission here is to really
get into how these systems of
organized force work, how they
keep going, and maybe the big
one, what role your behavior
plays and all that.
It's about understanding those
silent currents of power that
shape things.
Our main source for this deep
dive is this really thought
provoking sub stack post.
It's called flushing grouse.
The machine doesn't care who you
are and it offers this unique,
almost metaphorical way of
looking at how these systems
actually function.
When I first read it, I remember
thinking, wow, this is like
finding a hidden blueprint.
You know, it's not just about
the obvious stuff, but how the
whole underlying engine is
really designed.
It just shifts your focus from
the overt to the hidden dynamics
and.
What's really striking is how it
just cuts.
It's right through a lot of the
usual ways we think about this
stuff.
The central thesis is just laid
out there.
Force is the language, obscurity
is the shield.
It gives you this very primal,
almost ecological view of power
dynamics.
The core idea really is that for
any system of control to work,
police, regulators, even like
corporate HR, maybe it needs
visible prey.
Without something to act on,
something that you know makes
itself seen and therefore
actionable, the system kind of
struggles.
It struggles to justify itself,
keep its funding, keep
operating.
It's not just about using power,
it's about meeting a visible
target to even exist.
OK, so let's unpack that a bit.
This old truth the source talks
about, because it really feels
like the foundation here, it
says a quiet bird can't be shot,
a hidden fish can't be netted, a
calm suspect cannot be tagged
and processed into fuel for the
system.
And the source is basically
saying, look, this isn't some
radical new idea.
It's ancient.
It's how organized force has
always worked, like hunting
itself.
That's it, yeah.
And it really highlights the the
strategic upside of being
invisible.
Usually we think of power,
especially force.
Is this really obvious direct
thing like a hammer you.
Know very overt.
Exactly.
But this source suggests the
real lasting power isn't just
applying force, but maybe more
about creating the conditions
where force can be applied.
If something stays hidden,
quiet, calm, it just doesn't
even register.
It's effectively invisible,
unprocessible, and it really
challenges the idea that force
is always direct.
Maybe it's more about making
something visible first that's
the prerequisite.
And if you take that outside of
just like literal hunting or
policing, the implications get
pretty big, don't they?
Think about it.
The problem isn't loud and
visible, it's just simmering
under the surface, not making
waves.
Is it just less likely to get
dealt with by a system that kind
of needs visible problems to
react?
To like a corporation may be
ignoring low morale until it
blows up, or politics ignoring
quiet dissent until there are
protests.
Yeah, it feels like the system
is almost designed to focus on
what it can see and react to.
Like like a predator that only
chases what moves it.
Definitely raises that question
about engagement, doesn't it?
If invisibility is your shield,
then being visible inherently
makes you vulnerable, and the
source really drives this home
with this core operational
cycle.
Flushing what hides, tagging
what flushes, and feeding on
what becomes visible.
Everything else is noise.
It's not passive, it's
describing this active, almost
predatory loop.
The system isn't just waiting,
it's designed to draw things
out, make them visible so it can
keep going.
Right, it defines its own
reality by what it manages to
flush out.
Exactly.
So this idea of flushing things
out, it leads right into what
the source calls the system's
hunger.
It says pretty bluntly that any
system built to patrol, to
control or to manage human
behavior needs visible prey.
It needs movement, or the easy
spark of defiance, or even just
the sloppy mistake of pride to
basically justify itself its
whole existence.
Yeah, the budget, the
operations, the jobs.
Everything.
So without those visible things,
what happens?
Well, that's where this concept
of justification becomes so
fascinating.
Without that steady stream of
visible issues, identifiable
targets, these systems start to
shrink.
Police departments, regulatory
agencies, maybe even corporate
compliance teams.
Budgets get cut.
Staff might be reduced.
Like the source says, the
hunters go hungry.
And it's kind of flipped how we
normally think about them,
right?
We assume they exist only to
maintain order or enforce rules.
Which is part of it, sure.
Of course, but if there's
survival, their growth is
directly tied to finding visible
activity.
It points to this powerful,
almost biological self
preservation drive.
So visible defiance, mistakes,
even just making noise.
It becomes the fuel, the
perpetual motion machine that
keeps the system running and
proves its necessity.
It almost makes you wonder if
the system shrinks without prey,
does that create some kind of
incentive, maybe subtle, maybe
not, to find or even provoke
more prey?
That's the uncomfortable
question, isn't it?
Yeah.
Are there pressures to amplify
wrongdoing or find it where
maybe it wasn't quite so visible
before, just to keep the machine
fed and justify the resources?
It really challenges that purely
altruistic view.
It suggests this kind of cycle
where the system needs things to
manage and certain behaviors,
especially visible ones, provide
exactly that it needs to feed.
And the examples the source
gives are so vivid, almost
uncomfortably familiar.
Calls it pond stock, mouthy
drivers, panic runners,
intoxicated pride or social
media fueled bravado.
These aren't abstract ideas.
They're the things that well,
keep the machine running.
Things you see play out like the
source mentions in all those
dash Cam and body Cam videos
online.
It's the same pattern again and
again the.
Flapping wings, keeping the
machine alive.
Exactly.
It's a clear pattern, and once
you see it through this lens,
it's hard to ignore.
And this link between visible
behavior and the system
surviving?
It's critical because it leads
straight to the next big
metaphor, the Matrix one.
Yes, the Matrix allegory.
That one really hit home for me
in the movie.
Humans are literally batteries,
right?
Powering the system.
And the source draws this
parallel, saying that in our
world, it isn't your blood or
your breath that feeds the
system, it is your behavior.
And not just any behavior, but
specifically the moment you make
yourself visible enough to be
flushed.
That phrase is so potent.
Visible enough to be flushed.
Yeah.
And breaking down that behavior
is fuel.
Idea is really key.
The source is super specific
about what feeds the machine.
It lists things like every
unnecessary word, every I'll
timed question that is more a
provocation than a
clarification, every dramatic
what did I do?
Shouted at the wrong time.
Every push, every grab, every
swing.
Right.
It's not necessarily about
whether your actions are legal
or even morally right in some
abstract sense.
It's about their visibility in
that moment, their provocative
nature, their ability to trigger
an escalated response right then
and there.
It draws a Direct Line.
Your reaction fuels the system's
next move.
It pushes the interaction along.
So thinking about it that way
really changes how you see your
own agency in those moments,
doesn't it?
With authority or any
controlling system, it strongly
suggests that maybe, maybe
compliance in those specific
tense situations actually
preserves your autonomy better
than lashing out or demanding
your rights.
Which is so counterintuitive.
Totally.
We're taught to stand up for
yourself, challenge injustice.
But the source seems to say if
that assertion involves
flapping, you just become the
fuel the system needs to process
you.
It's a really hard pill to
swallow asking you to put aside
those ingrained ideas for a,
well, a pragmatic survival
strategy.
And the system's indifference.
That's maybe the most chilling
part of it all.
The source just lays it out.
The system does not care if you
are the daughter of a
billionaire in a luxury car or a
teenager with no shoes on a
dusty Rd.
Doesn't care about your resume,
your family, your intentions.
Nope.
If you flap, you feed it.
That universality is so
important to get.
It shows the machine's logic is
just operational.
It's not about personal bias or
status or understanding you.
It's just about whether your
behavior provides the spark, the
visible action that lets it keep
running.
Once you flap, you're just data
or resource, doesn't matter who
you are.
OK, so if our behavior is the
fuel, how does this whole flush
process actually start?
How do you get pulled into the
mechanism in the 1st place?
The source is pretty clear, it
almost always starts small,
really small.
Insignificant things.
A broken tail light.
A missing registration sticker.
A missed stop sign.
Right.
These aren't huge crimes,
they're the initial triggers,
often just minor slip UPS.
And what's so I guess effective
about them from the system's
point of view, is that they
provide this immediate, legally
sound, often undeniable reason
for interaction.
It's not some big conspiracy.
It's everyday stuff, often just
accidents.
But these little things act as a
legitimate pretext.
They let the system make
contact.
And, crucially, watch how you
behave.
That sets the stage for the
potential flush the system is
watching.
Will you stay quiet, or will you
become visible prey?
It's like the tripwire.
So the broken taillight isn't
the real issue, it's just the
doorway.
It gives them the legal foothold
to start talking to you, and
that's the moment where your
behavior suddenly becomes the
most important thing in the
equation.
Precisely.
And that distinction between the
initial trigger and what happens
next brings us right to what the
source calls the critical moment
of choice.
It lays out this stark contrast.
If you stay quiet and steady,
you know, show your hands and
say yes officer and no officer,
and let the moment stay small.
Then you often just melt back
into the brush as it says
disengage.
Right, that's the path of
obscurity, strategic retreat.
But then there's the other path.
What the source calls the
bristling is where it can all go
sideways if you let your pride
rise up, where you stand on your
rights in a way that is more
about display than survival.
That's when the dogs get closer.
Metaphorically, the encounter
starts to inflate, to escalate
way beyond that initial small
thing.
And that bristling is so
interesting psychologically,
isn't it?
It's driven by pride, maybe a
sense of injustice.
Maybe you're just not
understanding how power works in
that specific moment.
Yeah.
It's not about whether you have
rights legally speaking, it's
about how you assert them right
then.
Right.
The impulse is often to argue,
demand, push back.
But the source is saying that is
the very action that traps you.
It's pivotal because it makes
you ask, what's the real nature
of these encounters then?
Are they about justice?
Or are they fundamentally about
control, about power?
The source definitely implies a
kind of predatory dynamic.
Any flapping, any visible
defiance or emotional outburst
gets met with more force, more
escalation, And it traces that
path so clearly.
The simple stop becomes a
search.
The search becomes a scuffle.
The scuffle becomes resisting
arrest.
Yeah, turning a potential $100
fine into a life altering felony
record.
Exactly.
It describes it as a force
vector, indifferent to who you
are.
Once your behavior sets it off,
it just follows its own
relentless logic, often with
consequences way out of
proportion to the start.
And that chilling indifference
that brings us right to the next
really challenging idea, the
illusion that your status, your
place in society, can somehow
protect you from this.
Yes, the status shield.
It's a belief so many people
hold on to, maybe without even
realizing it, the source says.
Many people cling to the idea
that status will shield them,
that money, family connections
or a familiar last name can
protect them when the net
tightens.
It feels almost instinctual,
right?
If you're important, if you're
connected, you'll somehow get a
pass.
You'll be exempt.
And it's worth asking why that
belief is so common.
Is it past experience, Social
conditioning, or, like the
source suggests, just
fundamentally misunderstanding
how the system operates?
Because if the system truly
isn't different to who you are
and only cares about your
behavior.
Then your status, your money,
your connections, they become
irrelevant in that moment.
Exactly.
And that belief in immunity can
actually be a huge
vulnerability.
If you think your status
protects you, you might be more
likely to flap.
Right, you might argue or resist
because you assume there's a
safety net.
Yeah, feeling insulated by that
perceived immunity and that
overconfidence becomes its own
kind of trap.
So that insulation is just an
illusion according to this
source, once the system locks on
a dangerous miscalculation.
Completely.
The source is brutal and tearing
that down, it says.
But the feeding frenzy of force
does not check pedigrees when
the chase is on it.
It does not pause to ask whether
the suspect is royalty or nobody
at all.
And then that metaphor.
When the tension reaches a
certain pitch, the hunting
membrane slides down over the
shark's eye and everything in
reaches meat.
Wow, the shark's eye.
That's potent.
It suggests that once the system
goes into that feeding frenzy
mode, it's just primal,
instinctual.
No discrimination, no logic, no
external factors matter.
The internal logic, the hunger
for visible prey takes over.
Status, wealth, background.
All irrelevant because pure
unthinking force.
It's terrifying when you picture
that hunting membrane coming
down.
It means once you're flushed,
once it escalates, everyone
looks the same to the system
potential fuel.
And the source makes that point
so starkly.
That is why the same defines
that costs a kid.
A prison record can take down a
trust fund daughter just as
easily when her mouth moves
faster than her mind.
It's universal.
Doesn't matter if you have a top
lawyer on speed dial or you're
famous.
If you flap, the mechanism
doesn't care who you are, it
just processes the fuel.
It's like the ultimate perverse
equalizer strips away all those
external markers.
And this lack of discrimination
isn't just about status.
It also applies to how right you
think you are, or how just your
cause is.
OK, this is where it gets really
counterintuitive for a lot of
people, myself included.
Sometimes the source argues, and
so the pawn stays stalked.
The posters that say F the
police or defy or you're a
bootlicker might feel like
rebellion, but they are also
bait.
Bait.
Yeah, they keep the water
turning.
How can actions meant as
rebellion actually feed the
system they're trying to defy?
It turns resistance on its head.
Well, the insight here is about
redefining bait.
It's not necessarily something
evil or manipulative in itself,
it's just anything that
increases your visibility and
forces interaction with the
system, regardless of why you're
doing it.
So visible defiance, whether
it's from a righteous cause or
just pure frustration, it gives
the system justification fuel
for more budget, more gear, new
initiatives.
Right, it lets the system say.
See, look at this visible
problem.
We need more resources to deal
with this.
Exactly becomes the self
perpetuating cycle.
The more visible the defiance,
the more the system can
logically justify its own
expansion.
So the implications for, say,
social movements or civil
disobedience are huge.
Then does it mean certain kinds
of protest, especially the
really visible confrontational
ones, might accidentally be,
well, counterproductive within
this specific framework?
It raises that difficult
question.
If the system thrives on visible
defiance, then providing that
defiance, no matter how
well-intentioned, might just be
giving it more food, the source
says.
The more visible the defiance,
the more justification for more
dogs, more budgets, more gear
ending back at the snare that
never sleeps.
It paints this picture of a
snare tightening because of what
we see as resistance.
It forces you to ask what is
effective resistance if being
visible is the problem.
Which leads us right into the
nature of the trap itself.
Right.
If defiance is bait and status
is no help, how do you navigate
this once you're in it and the
source hits us with another hard
truth.
The harshest truth is that once
you step into the snare, it is
not a logic puzzle that you can
solve with the right words.
It is a dice.
Roll a dice roll, Yeah.
That's a massive shift from how
we usually think, isn't it?
We believe if we're just
rational, logical, say the right
things, we can control the
outcome, the source says.
Nope.
Dangerous illusion.
And it's crucial to ask why
isn't it a logic puzzle?
It goes against that deep belief
that reason, facts, clear
arguments should win out.
But the source suggests that
once the snare is sprung, once
the system is in feeding mode,
things like rationality,
fairness, even the precise law
might become secondary.
They become irrelevant to the
system's immediate goal.
Pretty much the drive to process
the visible prey takes over.
Your logical points might be
perfectly valid, but they don't
compute in that mode.
It's like the rules change mid
game, all your preparation, your
arguments might just bounce off
because the system isn't playing
that game anymore, it's switched
modes.
And the outcome becomes, as the
source says, unpredictable,
almost arbitrary.
Even if you do everything
technically correct, legally
justified, careful words, you
might still lose the role.
And it lists those external
factors you just can't control.
Maybe a District Attorney who
wants a trophy, or a jury who
hates the idea of civilians
using force.
Or, and this is so relevant
today, one damning angle on the
body Cam that overrides
everything else you said or did.
Just one snippet taken out of
context.
Right.
And the source notes that gun
owners, especially those who
carry concealed, understand this
better than most.
They know pulling a weapon, even
if legally justified
self-defense, is the absolute
last resort.
Why?
Because even if you're correct
in the moment, the aftermath is
a total gamble.
The stakes are immense.
Exactly.
That dice roll introduces this
systemic risk that's outside
your control, even if your
initial actions were right, just
lays bare at the power
imbalance.
You might be right legally and
morally, but that doesn't
guarantee you win the role.
The system has its own momentum,
its own goals.
It's a gamble you didn't ask
for.
OK, so given that
unpredictability, that power
gap, what's the alternative?
How do you actually win this
game?
And here's where we get to the
core maybe uncomfortable
strategic advice.
Yeah, the source says the best
armor is to avoid the role
altogether.
That feels like the absolute key
take away.
It completely flips the
definition of winning.
It's not about triumphing in the
fight, it's about avoiding the
fight completely.
It says.
People want to believe that the
system can be fair if only they
stand their ground loudly
enough, argue cleverly enough.
But no trap is fair.
That is the nature of traps.
And confronting why it's so hard
for us to accept that no trap is
fair is important.
It cuts against our basic sense
of justice, right, our belief
that if we're right, we should
win.
But the source argues, that
belief is exactly what makes us
more likely to flap, to engage,
resist, assert, and walk right
into the snare.
Because we think fairness should
apply.
Right.
And the imagery, so stark, the
more you flap, the more tightly
the news draws.
Resistance, regardless of
justification, just tightens the
trap's grip.
So this whole view really forces
you to reconsider what courage
or defiance means in these
specific moments.
Maybe true courage according to
this isn't confrontation.
Maybe it's strategic retreat?
Self preservation?
Being smart enough to see the
trap and not step in it, yeah.
It takes serious self-control.
Foresight often goes against
every immediate instinct, which
brings us to the ultimate
survival strategy, obscurity.
Right, staying hidden.
And this point directly tackles
those deep social norms that
internal conflict people feel.
The source says it flat out.
It is not cowardice to stay
small and silent.
It is not treachery to comply.
It is simply survival.
That hits hard because we're so
often told to stand up, fight
back, don't comply with
injustice.
But this reframes compliance in
these moments, not as weakness,
but as a deliberate strategic
act of self preservation
recognizing the real danger.
And it highlights how societies
focus on standing your ground.
Or defiance might ironically put
people in more danger.
Within this framework.
If defiance is bait and the
system is indifferent, than
insisting on fighting right then
might be the very thing that
traps you, leading to way worse
outcomes.
And those analogies?
Dr. at home.
A hidden grouse is never
flushed.
A calm pawn puts the hunter at
work.
It's about denying the system
the fuel it needs, rendering it
inert because there's nothing to
process strategic non
engagement.
Which leads to this very
specific, maybe limited, but
very real form of freedom.
The source puts it like this.
If there is any freedom left, it
lives in your decision not to
flap.
You know you do not control the
hunter, the dogs, the frenzy.
You only control whether you
give the machine the charge it
needs to survive another day.
That really pinpoints where your
actual control lies in these
skewed situations.
Just your own immediate
behavior, your reactions.
And it's vital to get that.
This isn't about controlling the
whole system or changing its
nature.
That's impossible.
It's about controlling your
input to it.
It's a very pragmatic, almost
minimalist freedom focused
purely on avoiding harm,
avoiding entanglement.
It's a stark definition of
freedom in these contexts, isn't
it?
Not the freedom to challenge,
but the freedom to basically
disappear from the radar.
And the source wraps up those
core ideas so concisely.
Force is the language.
Obscurity is the shield.
Pride is bait.
And then that final, chilling
universal truth.
And the law, when it moves,
moves with a blindness that does
not care whether you were born a
Princess or a baddie from the
block.
It cares only that you made
yourself big enough to catch
cold.
Impartial.
Just a mechanism.
It's all about not becoming
visible, not becoming fuel.
So what does this mean for us,
practically, For the listener?
The next time you feel that that
net Titan.
Well, the source offers some
pretty direct, actionable
advice, almost like a little
survival guide.
For those moments, it says,
remember this the next time you
feel the net Titan.
Keep your voice level.
Keep your wings folded.
It stresses maintaining that
composure, that level voice, and
avoiding any action, word,
gesture that makes you more
visible or seems like a
challenge.
Keeping those wings folded, it's
a strategic withdrawal.
Sounds so simple on paper,
doesn't it?
But I imagine doing that in the
moment when you're scared or
angry or feel totally wronged,
that's incredibly hard.
Oh, absolutely.
It demands huge mental
discipline, like suppressing
your pride, your gut reactions
for this cold, calculated
survival strategy.
Of course, almost as end
attachment sometimes.
But the source is clear.
It boils down to that really
powerful closing line.
The only winning move is to stay
too small to see strategically
vanish into the background
instead of becoming the focus of
the machines hunger.
So wow, we've really gone deep
into flesh and grouse today.
Unpack this fascinating, yeah,
unsettling view of how organized
force works.
We saw it doesn't just use
power, but it actively needs
visible prey to keep itself
going.
Right, the fuel.
We looked at the risks of
becoming that visible target,
the powerful illusion that
status protects you, and that
harsh reality of the dice roll
once you're caught.
And ultimately, the source makes
this compelling case that
compliance obscurity in these
specific moments, they aren't
weakness, they're pragmatic
survival strategies.
And these ideas, even if they're
challenging, they can really
change how you perceive those
everyday interactions with
authority gives you a different
kind of knowledge.
It's not about judging the
system or right versus wrong in
the usual sense.
It's about understanding the
specific power dynamic that's
always looking for visible
targets.
It's a tool really for
navigating those moments.
Definitely gives you a different
lens.
And as you, the listener, think
about all this, here's something
to chew on.
If the system really does feed
on visible defiance, and if this
source is right that
invisibility is the best shield,
then what does truly effective
resistance or maybe meaningful
change actually look like in
that kind of world?
Does it mean we need to totally
rethink how safety or justice or
even big societal shifts happen?
Maybe moving away from purely
overt confrontation towards
something more strategic, less
visible, indirect?
Perhaps it leaves you with that
powerful question sometimes.
Is the bravest thing you can do
simply not to flap?